this is Don Henry I am a vampire
I do consume human blood
there is a real live community that
exists not only within the states but
also well throughout the world according
to Henry he and his kind do not prey on
the innocent well these days we don't go
ripping people's throats out or anything
like that I'm quite mature with what we
do we keep things within doors we don't
go out searching for victims and I that
Henry claims he will only drink from
consenting donors but clearly there are
others who aren't so considerate in 1985
a motorist traveling down a back road in
Florida came across a young woman
handcuffed and partially clothed barely
able to walk the victim was rushed to
the local hospital where lieutenant Bob
letter O of the Brevard County Sheriff's
Department was brought in on the case
the doctors and the paramedics realized
that she had lost a significant amount
of blood and possibly could have passed
away from exposure just 19 years old the
girl had a terrifying story to tell she
informed me that she was out on the
roadway hitchhiking
this gentleman picked her up he looked a
very well dressed he offered her arrived
but once in the car the driver
overpowered her and choked her
unconscious it was then that the
nightmare really began she woke up later
on unknown the amount of time and she
was on a countertop in the kitchen she
was tied down and the suspect was
putting a needle syringe into her arm
and draining her blood out into a beaker
but why he said that he was a vampire
and that he drank off the blood
the nightmare continued for hours in
between feedings the kidnapper kept her
handcuffed in the bathtub it was through
the bathroom window still handcuffed
that she managed to escape onto the
nearby road
the victim in this case got away but
others have not